hannah is with us in Tennessee hi Hannah
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thanks for taking my call
sure what's up okay so we are kind of in
at night and we are 117 on our home we
have about forty thousand dollars in car
votes and about two thousand dollars in
credit card debt yeah forty thousand
dollars in car what long car loans good
lord
okay and how much in credit card debt mm
okay and how much your student loans no
okay and what other debt other than your
own um just get the cars okay and what's
your household income about 63 okay and
tell me about the cars break them down
for me is it more than one loan um yes
it's two lines we have a 16 Kia Sorento
that we go like 21 at 21,000 and then we
have a 2012 Jeep Wrangler is that we go
$21,000 as well so 21 on each of them
yeah okay way too much tied up in cars
yeah way out of control
I would actually recommend selling both
of them I'll get you about to $5,000
cars you should not have more than half
your annual income tied up in vehicles
even if they're paid for
so that would be $30,000 worth so if you
want to keep one of these that's fine
but you guys are car poor big time you
got $1,000 a month going out and car
payments yeah we won't refinance because
we couldn't afford any financing for 72
months and one car payments for 25 and
one 373 yeah kind of like $1,000 yeah
yeah okay yes so my question is I know
that the cars are an issue and that
should be never one but we are we bought
a fixer-upper
we were DIY people and we are not so I
would like to sell the house because
there is equity in it as it is but my
husband loves the house and wants to
stay a month to fix it I don't see where
I feel worse than where's the breakdown
where's the understanding he thinks
she's a DIY person but you don't he he
wants to fix it he won't know he thinks
he's a DIY you just said we are not DIY
people and then you said he can't do
anything so he's going to pay someone
okay so you're not do it yourself but
you won't pay a contractor and fix it up
but to look at what we need on the roof
we need new windows
we need new electrical we need a signal
what what the house smell for as is as
is we could probably get about 160 out
of it that's cool and take like $50,000
out and get debt-free and by me house
yeah buy a house that doesn't need a
bunch of fixing up and your whole family
just suddenly got stabilized right
that's the way I see that does not
include you keeping these insane cars
even if you pay them off their insanity
you do not want to have listen cars
could lose 60 to 70 percent of their
value in the first four years you have
so much tied up in things going the
wrong way these are going down in value
rapidly and you've got over half your
annual income tied up in vehicles that
are going down in value it's it's
killing you you really can't win this
way I'm not against cars I'm just
against cars owning you and so even if
you paid them off one of them's got to
go and be you know be down to about a
$9,000 car on the other one because you
don't you cannot have more than $30,000
in vehicles if you're making 60 and
prosper does that make sense to you
women stop don't stop stop stop
does that make sense yeah okay so if
you're if you're willing to do that and
pay off the other car and sell the sell
get a $9,000 car pay off the other one
and pay off the credit cards and cut
them up and get on a budget use the
what's left over to buy another house
leaving out an emergency fund
I would sell this thing in a heartbeat
you cannot afford to do the renovation
your home is disorganized as a result of
the renovation needing to be done and
you're not prospering in this setting
with all this chaos you've got financial
chaos I just hear disorganization now
all through this discussion and you want
to get everything calmed down and
settled and Bubba still wants to do a
hamstring a hammer over here and it's
just not going to happen I wouldn't do
it
I don't mind fixing up a house I don't
know my Nona nice cars I don't mind
doing this but not when that's screwing
up your life and all these things are
screwing up your all's life and you are
you figured that out so yeah you win the
argument you need to sell the house but
only if you're willing to do these other
things because the house is just part of
the equation the cars are part of the
equation the stupid overspending and
using credit cards as part of the
equation then no budget is part of the
equation that no emergency funds part of
the equation all of that and when you do
all that and smooth all that out all of
a sudden you're gonna feel like you have
a completely new life here and it's
gonna be a better life hang on I want to
send you a copy of the book the Total
Money Makeover both of you read every
word and do it and I will show you how
to be in a whole lot better place two
years from today
good questions thank you for calling in